hey guys this is dennis and this is my
review of gamma del Toro's Pacific Rim
let's just get right into it I love the
movie I grew up watching godzilla
Voltron played with a little
transformers old for man all that stuff
anything was like giant robots or giant
monsters I loved in and watching this
movie made me feel like I was a kid
again all the action and and sequences
with the monsters and the robots
battling out it was kind of like when
you you were little and you had little
toys and you would have them fight each
other even though they weren't even in
the same same universe or same a cartoon
or movie or TV show yeah sure some of
the story elements and the plot and the
characters were predictable and some
things were a little cheesy here and
there but but I think that kind of
worked with what the movie was you know
the movie wasn't trying to be anything
else it was just trying to be like
over-the-top spectacle action
entertainment and and I know a lot of
people say oh oh Michael boo does that
or you know but the difference between
Pacific Rim and let's say transformers
is I think Pacific Rim knows what type
of movie it is and it doesn't take
itself seriously where transformers you
know a lot of the humor falls flat the
action isn't isn't that fun you know
it's it's very bloated scenes don't go
from place to place it just doesn't make
much sense but something like this it's
pretty straightforward you know you know
what the characters want to do you know
what their their goal is I mean this
movie was a lot like a independence day
in a way like a lot of the same plot
points and stuff like that and
characters even but in this it was I
think even better than independence day
one because the action was just simply
better that you have the visual effects
of the robots and the monsters and like
the size everything I saw this in imax
in 3d and like seeing all the all the
fights on the giant big screen it was
just like so amazing and you could see
the scale of everything because guerra
de Toro made sure that you would see the
buildings and little helicopters and
people and cars and stuff like that so
that you could always tell how big the
these giant robots and kaiju monsters
and the jaegers which is with the giant
robots so before I get further into this
review if you haven't seen it yet i'm
gonna go into a little few spoilers here
and there if you haven't seen that idea
i highly recommend going to check it out
and come back and watch this review so
as I mentioned like the the visual
effects an action was great like you
could always see what was going on
unlike with transformers like sometimes
like when things are moving around
really fast you can't see anything
they're all closed up but in this you
see like every punch and every movement
and it's not too fast and it's not too
shaky it's not too too close up you
really feel the weight of these giant
robots you know it's weird cuz in a way
they're moving slower than other things
that you've seen but it ends up actually
feeling a lot more impactful because of
how how big they are and how slow
they're moving but when they hit and the
another thing is a sound design the
sound design actually makes you feel the
impact of all the hits and stuff like
that um music I thought was great some
people complained about the music they
didn't like it cuz they thought might
have it was been too cheesy but I
thought it fit right in you know with
the with the big giant battle scenes you
know as far as the acting goes I thought
it was fine you know people kind of get
confused they always confused bad acting
and bad dialogue like when it with a
really good actor delivers a line and he
does it well but the line of dialogue is
actually not very good line people make
the mistake of thinking oh he that was
some bad acting but actually sometimes
it's not sometimes just the dialogue
like for example Idris Elba who plays
the main commander stacker Pentecost and
and I love I love a dress l but he you
know ever since I saw him in the wire is
stringer Bell he also played a Lutheran
Luther in the BBC show he's a fantastic
actor and this he's great as well you
know even though not all the lines of
dialogue or you know that great he still
delivers them he's
very magnetic and he brings a lot of
charisma and weight to his performance
Raleigh's relationship with Mako I
thought that was fine I mean it wasn't
like anything new that we haven't seen
before but I thought it worked and i
also thought Makos relationship with
idris elba's character stacker I thought
that also was worked fine you know it
wasn't anything you didn't see coming at
the same time it works in the emotional
level of being invested in these
characters and so when they did fight it
like it made you feel much more engaged
one of my favorite things to was being
able to see that the two co-pilots that
were having the neural bridge how they
were fighting how you could see them
inside at the same time as they were
moving so all their movements were being
mimicked by the giant jaegers yet really
cool Jaeger designs you had [ __ ] danger
which was the main one that uh that
Raleigh and Mako were in and he had my
personal affair was the church Cherno
alpha 1 is the Russian was a mark 1 the
only problem was it got beat up pretty
fast in the only fight that it was in
but I thought the design was really cool
had the hammer fists crimson typhoon was
that the the China one and you had
striker which was the australian one so
my favorite scene was actually the in
the middle of the movie when all three
of the other jaegers either get beat up
or they got a strikers case they got you
know frozen by the EMP and then when
[ __ ] danger came beat up that
ape-looking monster one they kicked his
ass with the the plasma cannon and then
after that he fought the the winged one
that took him up in the air and he he
sliced him I thought those two were the
best battles in the entire movie I mean
the ending was pretty cool to the end
battle sequence but I thought the the
ones in the middle with with [ __ ]
danger were the best he also had some
comedy with Charlie days character the
dr. Newton and Ron Perlman is Hannibal
Chau I thought those things really cool
I mean the thing is you can't have all
just fighting the entire time you need
breathers and you know they had breathe
is in the form of a cut some drama and
then also with some comedy and I thought
it worked well I like Charlie day in
that role also how funny was that scene
with ron perlman that mid-credits one
mid end credits like after the movie was
over like after the first set of credits
there was a ron perlman coming and cut
it coming out of the baby Kaidu stomach
I thought that was pretty cool and
looking for a shoe so I definitely
recommend seeing this movie I recommend
seeing in imax and 3d i'm gonna give an
a-minus yeah the the the story wasn't
anything that great but i think it did
his job I think it kind of paid tribute
to all the giant robot and giant
monsters stories that we've seen in the
past and in Japanese anime and stuff
like that now the question is is there
gonna be a sequel well right now it
doesn't look like it we have it's made
about 38 million dollars for its opening
weekend which isn't terrible but
considering is 190 million dollar budget
it's not what it needs to be you know
people were kind of hoping for 50 or 60
million dollar opening and that didn't
happen international he's doing better
it's at 50 million but unless like
internationally keeps doing well and it
holds steady in our domestic the u.s.
box off the numbers I don't think we're
gonna see sequel I would really love to
see a sequel I really love this movie
but I think I think I think I'm gonna
have to just accept the fact that
there's not gonna be another one alright
guys so that's what I thought of Pacific
Rim let me know your thoughts you can
post your comments below on the YouTube
video and on our website make sure you
follow me on Twitter or mines at think
here we can ask me questions you can
find me on Facebook or think hero fans
and also make sure to subscribe to our
channel that's a think hero pro
you